ja servus klickzoom hier ist juliina 7
vielleicht kennt man mich von meinen
Gaming Videos vielleicht kennst du mich
auch von Twitter keine Ahnung ja meine
Frage an laviv mich interessiert einfach
weil ich natürlich auch stöber auf
Youtube und mir aufgefallen ist dass die
Version mit Esra vom
Video ja sehr viel besser ankommt dass
viele sich gewünscht hätten dass Esra in
der Band ist
und ja dass ein Mitglied das es jetzt
geschafft hat nicht dabei ist ja mich
interessiert einfach wie geht ihr damit
um dass sie so viele Menschen andere
member in der Band gewünscht hätten ihr
könnt ja natürlich nichts
dafür und wahrscheinlich seid ihr jetzt
auch mittlerweile froh dass ihr so
zusammen seid aber natürlich ist es auch
eine Sache des Erfolges wenn sich
wirklich sehr viele andere Menschen
die
Band in anderen Besetzung gewünscht
hätten ja danke für eine eventuelle
Antwort und ich bin jetzt mal raus hier
bis
denn ja also eine weitere Antwort wir
haben das Video von Esra auf Youtube
natürlich auch gesehen das heißt ja da
LAV featuring Esra also erstmal dazu
laviv besteht aus Katrin Maike SAR und
mir und nicht nur aus uns dreien
featuring
von daher ist dieses Video für mich
schon mal unnütz zweitens das Video
ist ins Netz gekommen weil jemand den
Maulwurf gespielt hat und was Falsches
gemacht hat und es wird niemals ein
laviv featuring Esra oder laviv mit Esra
geben weil wir wurden so von euch
gewählt und ich meine wir wissen alle
dass Esra sehr viele Fans hat aber wenn
Esra mehr Fans hätte als Katrin wäre sie
jetzt in der Band von daher ihr ihr
lieben Leute habt uns so gewählt und ähm
ja laviv ist vollständig und leider ohne
Esser aber wir haben die liebe Katrin
dabei und das ist ganz gut
so